hoy vamos a hablar de los sindicatos de
trabajadores en grupos que varios
sectores empresariales generan el
rechazo incluso algunas corporaciones
están completamente prohibidos y podrían
ser incluso motivo de despido pero ahora
después de la pandemia estos sindicatos
aumentaron nos acompaña en nuestro
estudio en nuestra cronista de revista
de prensa rosa pérez masdéu que pues lo
que estuvieron acompañándonos en la
primera hora pudieron ver todo el
contexto que nos hizo rosa entonces por
estos sindicatos rosa muy buen día
bienvenida nuevamente buenos días de
nuevo a raúl y también saludamos a jaime
carol es doctora en historia
contemporánea de eeuu por la universidad
autónoma de madrid convención
internacional por columbia university
especializado en sindicalismo gracias
jaime o por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france24 rosa bueno
buenos días jaime si le parece empecemos
hablando de la aprobación del movimiento
sindical en eeuu porque según una
encuesta de gallup esta aprobación se
situaría ahora mismo en torno al 68 por
ciento lo que representaría el pico más
alto de aprobación
respecto a
1965 cuando esta aprobación estaba en el
71 por ciento siendo el punto más bajo
2009 cuando la aprobación se situaba por
debajo del 50% entonces empecemos
repasando cuáles serían los factores que
han propiciado esta tendencia al alza en
la aprobación del movimiento sindical en
eeuu bueno el factor clave que ha
incluido que ha influido en esta
aprobación del sindicalismo de eeuu es
claramente la pandemia de lakovic de
2019 esta pandemia hizo que muchísimos
trabajadores que en su época bueno que
durante la pandilla francos era como
trabajadores esenciales y que cobraba
bastante poco considerasen que a ser
tratado de trabajadores sociales
esenciales al terminar o terminar la
pandemia o ahí terminando la pandemia
vieron que efectivamente sin ellos y el
mundo no podía seguir siendo el mundo no
podía seguir funcionando entonces
consideraron que debería cobrar más
sobre todo me estoy definiendo a los que
repartían a domicilio a los que reparten
por ejemplo a los trabajadores atendé
amazon o incluso a trabajadores
esenciales del mundo de la restauración
de la hostelería como podría ser starmax
fue el punto clave que hizo que en el
sindicalismo de eeuu volviese a ser
aprobado con estas tasas de aprobación
aún así hay que decir que el
sindicalismo de eeuu sigue teniendo una
acción alguna tendencia a la negativa me
refiero a que cada vez hay menos
trabajadores sindicalizados aunque
parece que ahora se está intentando
revertir esta tendencia desde el
sindicalismo ya vamos a hablar de esa de
esa tendencia que pues por ahora no está
como en su máximo momento pero le quiero
preguntar a mí por la importancia de los
sindicatos en el sector laboral por la
importancia de los sindicatos para los
trabajadores
son los sindicatos son esenciales porque
solo a correa de transmisión entre las
demandas de los trabajadores hacia el
patrón vuelto ayudar la empresa en eeuu
como la mayoría de las empresas son
pymes pequeñas y medias siempre se han
considerado que estas demandas estaban
ya totalmente
encadenadas en el proceso de producción
puesto que
estamos imaginario de la empresa como
una familia de un trabajador individual
podría perfectamente ir al dueño de la
empresa increíble pues un juramento de
salario o cierta activa de
prerrogativas en cambio los sindicatos
son muy importantes porque son
asociación de un montón de trabajadores
de un grupo grande de trabajadores que
conjuntamente hacemos las demandas
colectivas que no solamente son con
respecto al salario puede ser con
respecto a la seguridad dentro de su
ámbito de trabajo por ejemplo para
trabajadores de la hostelería la
seguridad en el ambiente de trabajo
puede ser incluso que los suelos están
hechos de un material esponjoso para que
así no sufran las rodillas pero por
ejemplo en el caso de amazon la
seguridad puede ser perfectamente que
como vimos la noticia creo que el año
pasado que si hay una alerta de tornado
y la
y almacenes que están trabajando no
cumple la seguridad suficiente bien
primero de todo que se vayan a su casa
ese día y luego que la empresa invierta
dinero para que ese almacén sea mejorado
por lo tanto la importancia 3
sindicalismo dentro del mundo del
trabajo es esencial diría yo
precisamente y usted nos daba los
ejemplos de trabajadores de la
hostelería o de amazon o que sería un
caso paradigmático del capitalismo de
plataformas en el que nos encontramos
entonces cuáles serían las diferencias
en el movimiento sindical de este
paradigma económico actual respecto al
capitalismo industrial cuando surgieron
estos a estas organizaciones
sí claro aquí es muy diferente este tipo
de sindicalismo que se enfrentó en su
época al carnet de mando e industrial
por ejemplo en estados unidos el mayor
sindicalismo que existía o la
experiencia sindicalista existía en la
zona del
óxido que es la cual que hacía coches
uno vaciado industrial del capitalismo
de coches fábrica de coches de ford
general motors que nos situaríamos por
por la zona de michigan y claro era muy
fácil en esa época hacer sindicalismo
porque prácticamente todos los
trabajadores de la misma empresa estaban
en el mismo puesto de trabajo en cambio
con el capitalismo digital o el capaz y
con el capitalismo de plataformas nos
damos cuenta que por ejemplo que los
trabajadores de amazon que están en
nueva york con amazon de nueva york o en
un almacén en la habana y no tienen con
quién hablar de la compañía exactamente
y pueden hablar con un manager que es
solamente encargado de salma cen pero
que no se encarga en teoría de todos los
almacenes de eeuu por lo tanto
un gran problema de correa de
transmisión y es algo que se enfrenta a
estar este nuevo sindicalismo que
precisamente se llama no os indicaremos
por eso porque si antes si el
sindicalismo se podía dar el mismo
puesto de trabajo en la misma fábrica en
el mismo restaurante ahora el
sindicalismo se tiene que abonar a
trabajadores que no se conocen entre
ellos que no son que no serán jamás
entre ellos y que cae en distintos
puntos en este sentido de la geografía
estadounidense pero no podemos olvidar
que por ejemplo crisis es más el líder
del sindicato además el euro reunión
dijo que éste era el primer sindicato
que se había creado en eeuu pero que
quería una vocación internacional es
decir quería por ejemplo probarlo por
todos los almacenes que hay en
latinoamérica en españa en filipinas y
eso es el área
jaime porque porque esto no pasa digamos
porque algunas empresas muchas empresas
digamos los ven como representados una
amenaza cuáles son a más las políticas
anti sindicalistas que tienen las
empresas y porque rechazan este
colectivo de trabajadores
bueno en ha habido el movimiento
sindical de ahora mismo en eeuu hay dos
polos que son starmax como somos como ha
hablado y amazon ambas compañías se
están contratando a otras compañías que
se dedican a intentar pues desmantelar
es por un tanto de sindicalismo en la
compañía por ejemplo en amazon tenemos
que han contratado a la agencia
pinkerton que en su época al principio
de su 19 ya se hablaba de hacer este
tipo de trabajo antisindical y porque lo
hace porque perderían se calculan amazon
ha calculado que perdería millones de
dólares solamente dando 15 minutos más
de descanso a todos los trabajadores que
trabajan en su almacén porque están con
un proceso de tecnologización de sus
almacenes para que todo sea más rápido
para que cuando tus vidas por amazon te
llegas de 10 a 24 días y no a la semana
pues si por ejemplo una de las grandes
demandas que tiene la franja del amazon
es aumentar los trajes de los descansos
en el trabajo perderían millones de
dólares en ese sentido
por ejemplo una de las mayores demandas
que hay es que se cumplan están en lo
mínimo general que hay en eeuu que
serían 15 dólares la hora y según la
última cálculos están cobrando entre los
8 y los 9 dependiendo de la ciudad y del
estado por lo tanto estamos hablando que
tendrían que doblar el salario por lo
tanto ahí se ve
el choque entre el patrón por así
decirlo o el dueño de la empresa y al
trabajo y el trabajador esa
contradicción eterna en el cual el
trabajador quiere por ejemplo más
salario o más demandas para subir estar
y que eso repercute totalmente en
crédito de la empresa va a cobrar menos
dinero o va a tener menos beneficios
clave precisamente
esta ideología
corporativista o tendría alguna
influencia en el hecho de que a pesar de
que estemos hablando de una tendencia al
alta en la aprobación todavía la
afiliación sea muy baja respecto a los
años 60 del siglo pasado
sí claro toda esta ideología
corporativista como han mencionado
tiene mucho que ver con esto con que la
tendencia se llama negativa porque las
campañas que salen antes indicadas en
eeuu son claras muy amplias y son muy
destructivas y buscan sobre todo que los
trabajadores no se vean representados
por ese sindicalismo ya no solamente el
miedo siempre que ha espoleado eeuu sea
su sociedad debido al comunismo es el
ese es el miedo al representante por lo
tanto esa ideología es el máximo
beneficio ya no me importa si los
trabajadores están reclutados